بعد استهداف المدمره الامريكيه في البحر
الاحمر بريطانيا تدخل بحامل طائراتها وابو
اليمن يضرب سفينه امريكيه جديده وتقرير
استخباراتي امريكي خطير حول هدف محتمل قد
يتم استهدافه من قبل الجيش اليمني روسيا
تصرح الممارسات الامريكيه في البحر الاحمر
غير مسموح بها وبسبب معارك البحر الاحمر
اسعار الشحن ترتفع بين اوروبا والصين
بنسبه
400% ومدير السي اي اي الشرق الاوسط مقبل
على انفجار كبير مصر تضغط وبشده على تل
ابيب لايقاف الحرب فهل تنجح طرف الصراع في
السودان يجريان اول محادثات رفيعه المستوى
واردوغان يزور مصر بعد خلاف وقطيعه دامت
السنوات سعي امريكي الماني لتاخير عمليه
انضمام اوكرانيا الى الناتو والكونغرس
يجمد المساعدات
الاوكرانيه البحر الاحمر
يشتعل الجيش اليمني لا يتوقف عن استهداف
السفن في البحر الاحمر والبحر العربي وبعد
ساعات من اعلان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه
انها اطلقت عده صواريخ بحريه مناسبه على
المدمره الامريكيه يو اس اس ريفل في البحر
الاحمر اعلن المتحدث العسكري باسم الجيش
اليمني يحيى سريع انهم نفذوا عمليه نوعيه
استهدفت السفينه التجاريه الامريكيه كول
وكان الجيش الامريكي اعلن تدمير صاروخ قبل
اطلاقه في اليمن مثل تهديد لطائرات
امريكيه قبل ذلك ذكرت صحيفه التليغراف
البريطانيه ان البحريه الملكيه تستعد
لاستبدال حامله الطائرات الامريكيه يو اس
اس دوايت ايزنهاور نظرا لعودتها الى
الولايات المتحده وياتي القرار البريطاني
بعد اعلان حكومه صنعاء انهم مستعدون
لمواجهه طويله الامد ليؤكد مندوب روسيا
الدائم لدى مجلس الامن الدولي فاسيلي
نيبينزيا بان ممارسات امريكا وبريطانيا في
البحر الاحمر تذكرنا باسوا الاوقات في
للقصف غير القانوني لحلف شمال اطلسي
الناتو على يوغسلافيا وافغانستان وسوريا
وفق وكاله سبتنك وفي تقرير لصندوق النقد
الدولي اكد ارتفاع تكاليف الشحن البحري
بين اوروبا والصين لاكثر من 400% منذ
منتصف نوفمبر الماضي وبسبب تصاعد الوضع
الامني في البحر الاحمر اثيرت مخاوف الدول
الغربيه بشان اثر الصراع على التجاره
وتكاليف الشحن ليخرج مدير الاستخبارات
الامريكيه سي اي اي ويليام بيرنز ويقول
انه لم يشاهد منذ اربعه عقود اوضاع قابله
للانفجار بالشرق الاوسط كما هي اليوم
مؤكدا ان مخاطر التصعيد على جبهات اخرى في
الشرق الاوسط قائمه بحسب مجله فورين اوفرز
هنا رد خبراء مصريون على تقرير خطير نشره
موقع منتدى الخليج الدولي يفيد بان
الكبلات البحريه الحيويه قد تكون هدفا
جديدا لهجمات ابو اليمن المقبله في البحر
الاحمر واضاف ان استهداف الكابلات البحريه
ان حدث سيمثل تغييرا
وتوسيعاً العالمي المرتبطه بدول شرق اسيا
ما يؤكد ان المعركه ستستمر لمده اطول وها
نحن نتصفح
المصدر لازلنا في مصر حيث ذكرت صحيفه
معاريف العبريه ان القاهره تضغط على تلبيب
من اجل انهاء الحرب الجاريه على القطاع
قبل شهر رمضان المقبل حتى لا تنفجر
الاوضاع في المنطقه بالك فيما نقلت قناه
كان 11 العبريه عن مصادر مطالعه قولها ان
هناك مخاوف من انه اذا لم يحدث ذلك فان
الوضع في المنطقه سيتصاعد بشكل اكبر ويخرج
عن نطاق السيطره على ذكر الضغوطات
الخارجيه افادت صحيفه واشنطن بوست بان
الولايات المتحده زادت ضغوطها على تلبيب
والفصائل خوفا من تصعيد الصراع بشكل اكبر
وتحاول حث الطرفين على التوصل الى هدنه
واشارت الى ان السلطات الامريكيه تعتزم
خفض حده الاعمال القتاليه في المنطقه وتر
ركيز مره اخرى على الجهود الدبلوماسيه
لتطبيع العلاقات بين العبريين والسعوديه
بالمقابل هاجم وزير الامن القومي العبري
ايتمار بن غفير الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه متسائلا هل بداوا اداره الدوله
العبريه رسميا مشددا على اننا لن نصبح
جمهوريه موز ولن نصبح
ماعزا هذا ويزور الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان مصر في فبراير في مسعا لتحصين
العلاقات بعد عقد من توتر الروابط بين
البلدين وفق ما افاد مسؤول اتراك ل
بلومبرج التي قالت ان المحادثات بين
اردوغان ونظيره المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
يتوقع ان تركز على الشحنات المساعده
للمدنيين في القطاع والخطوات التي يمكن
اتخاذها لانهاء الحرب وفق ما افادت به
مصادر تركيا فيما وضع البنتاجون القوات
الجويه الامريكيه المتمركزه في العراق في
حاله تاهب استعدادا لنشرها في حاله القيام
بعمليه بريه امريكيه دعما للقوات العبريه
في القطاع وعلى الرغم من وعود بايدن بعدم
ارسال قوات الى الارض فان وثائق حصل عليها
موقع ذا انترسبت تشير الى ان الجيش استعد
لهذا الاحتمال ولنضع المصدر
امامكم وبين هذا وذاك ذكرت صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه ان ايران حذرت
الولايات المتحده عبر وسطاء امين جرار
الجانبين الى صلاع مباشر وحسب الصحيفه فان
طهران وجهت تحذيرا الى واشنطن من انه اذا
هاجمت الاخره اراضيها بشكل مباشر فان
اهران ستلحق الضرر بالاصول الامريكيه في
الشرق الاوسط وسوف ينجر الجانبان الى صراع
مباشر في السودان طرف الصراع يجريان اول
محادثات رفيعه المستوى حيث سلطت وكاله
رايترز للانباء الضوء على اتفاق جرى بين
طرفي الصراع في السودان باجراء اول
محادثات رافيعه المستوى في البحرين واشارت
الوكاله نقلا عن مصادر ان قاده كبارا من
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
اجتمعوا ثلاث مرات هذا الشهر في البحرين
في اول تصعيد على هذه الدرجه بين الجانبين
المتحاربين في الصراع المستعير منذ تسعه
اشهر سعي امريكي
الماني رغبه امريكيه تعاكس ما يحلم به
الاوكرانيين حيث نقلت مجله فورين بوليسي
عن مصادر ان الولايات المتحده والمانيا
تسعيان الى تاخير بدء عمليه انضمام
اوكرانيا الى الناتو رغم رغبه دول اوروبا
الشرقيه وكيابل ذلك في اقرب وقت واضافت
المجله ان بولندا ودول البلطيق ترى ان
توسع النتو من خلال عضوي اوكرانيا هو
وسيله لاضعاف طموحات روسيا في اوروبا
الشرقيه من جانبه اعلن المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون باتريك رايدر ان الولايات
المتحده لن تعلن عن ارسال دفعات جديده من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا من مخزوناتها
العسكريه بسبب عدم وجود موافقه من
الكونجرس بحسب سبوتنك هنا صرحت صحيفه
ادفانس الكرواتيه بان بعض الدول المجاوره
لاوكرانيا وبتحديد بولندا والمجر قد تبدان
في تقسيم اراضي اوكرانيا بعد هزيمه قوات
نظام كياف واضافت الصحيفه ان مثل هذا
التحول من شانه ان يصدم العالم اجمع بلا
شك لانه سيمثل بدايه حقبه جديده بالعوده
الى واشنطن قالت مجله فوربس انه رغم اصرار
الجمهوريين بالكونجرس على تجميد المساعدات
لاوكرانيا للشهر الرابع تقوم اداره الرئيس
جو بايدن بتزويد كياف بالاسلحه والذخيره
عبر اليونان ونقلت المجله عن وسائل اعلام
يونانيه ان الولايات المتحده ستقوم بنقل
الاسلحه القديمه الفائضه الى اليونان بشرط
ان تمنح اوكرانيا جزءا من الفائض لديها من
جهتها قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زاخاروفا في ايجاز صحفي ان
روسيا ستعتبر مصادره الاتحاد الاوروبي
لاصوله بمثابه حرب تجاريه سيشكل ذلك
انتهاكا صارخا للقانون الدولي ولننتقل الى
الحرب الاوكرانيه فقد اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن استعاده 195 عسكريا روسيا من
الاسر الاوكراني مقابل نفس العدد من الاسر
الاوكرانيين وفق الموقع الرسمي للحكومه
الروسيه وعلى الارض قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين انه من الضروري نقل خط
المواجهه الى مسافه تحمي سلامه المدن
المسالمه من القصف كما تضمن المنطقه
منزوعه السلاح في اوكرانيا سلامه المدن
الحدوديه ويصرح الممثل الاعلى للاتحاد
الاوروبي لشؤون الخارجيه والسياسيه
الامنيه جوز بورال ان البعثه التدريبيه
للاتحاد المتخصصه بتدريب العسكريين
الاوكرانيين دربت حتى الان 40 الف عسكري
اوكراني ومن المقرر ان تدرب 20 الف اخرين
خلال العام
الحالي
[موسيقى]
ا